اصابه جديده تصل الى المستشفى الميداني
وعلى الدكتور قدري ان يقف على حالتها
وصلت هذه السيده للتو علينا ان نشخص
اصابتها اصابتها تبدو حديثه وقعت على
الارض وبدات حجاره الحائط تتساقط فوقي
يذهب المسعفون بالسيده للعلاج هنا في واحد
من المستشفيات الميدانيه في اديمان التي
انشات كاستجابه طارئه لزلزال كهرمان مراش
دليلنا الطبيب المسؤول عن المستشفى
واذا كانت لاصابه بالغه ننقل للمصابين جوا
الى مستشفيات اكثر تجهيزا
في المدينه المنكوبه تستمر الحالات
بالتوافد هذا الشاب نجا من تحت الانقاض
وفرق والده وبعض اقاربه الحياه
كنت في الطابق الثاني عندما انهار المنزل
وبدا الحطام يتساقط فوقي وفي غرفه ثانيه
رجل مصاب يبحث عن ابنته
فقدت ابنتي ولا استطيع ايجادها وزوجتي في
العنايه الفائقه
يسمح لنا الطبيب بتفقد غرفه العمليات في
المستشفى الذي ساهم في انقاذ عشرات
الارواح في المدينه وهنا تساؤل هل يمكن
للطواقم الطبيه ان تبقى خارج نطاق التاثر
بحجم الماساه المحيطه بهم
نشعر بمعاناتهم بالماساه لكننا يجب ان
نتصرف بمهنيه عاليه بعيدا عن مشاعرنا
نترك الطبيب وفريقه ونسمع بينهم همسات قلق
على عائلتهم البعيده وعن المستقبل القريب
وصف مشهد الدمار العظيم في المدن المنكوبه
اذا تعمل الاف الفرق الطبيه بصمت حاولنا
التعرف على قليل مما يقومون به ليبقى
الجهد الاكبر لهؤلاء متجليا في قصص ملايين
الناجين من الزلزال سلام خضر الجزيره
الديامون